I wondered if I could get your view on
the fact that the Prime Minister has
received a fixed penalty notice for not
wearing a seat belt it's the second time
he's had a fixed penalty notice from
police do you think the Rishi sunac
should consider his position
I think it just makes Ricky sooner look
ridiculous I mean if you think about
this week you know we end this week
let's look back at what's happened
you've had kissed armor has been a good
World economic Forum uh trying to
promote Britain trying to get investment
in the UK setting out our plan for
economic growth and so on and meanwhile
you've got Richie sooner you can't even
fasten his own seat belt and I think
basically it just makes the government
look ridiculous and that they are not up
to running the country
well he would say he was on very
important business uh sorting out and
explaining his leveling up fund up and
down the country and he did own up
straight away didn't he to this and and
if you just look on social media you can
see there are plenty of photographs and
videos of of Labor leaders who at times
haven't been wearing seat belts as well
do you think the whole thing's a bit
overblown
I think it adds to a sense that Richard
simack is just not on top of his job but
he's not on top of what's going on but
he's not really up to this um and that
they haven't really they're not really
in control
um of what's going on I mean if he can't
pass anything his own seat belt you know
how is he going to run the country
um I think that you make a point about
the you know the size of the penalty
um and and how serious it is you know it
does reflect on the Prime Minister but
obviously there's another penalty that
we're talking about in the news at the
moment which is you know Dean zahawi uh
reported to have paid a much larger
penalty uh for an apparent failure to
pay his taxes correctly you know that's
really serious as well but again that
circles back to the Prime Minister
because you know Nadim zahari has been
appointed as the chair of the
conservative party by Richie soon act as
a wise refusing act letting him continue
in this position
yes those are allegations made this week
against the conservative party chairman
the guardian as you say
um adding to the reports alleging that
the money paid to hmrc by the former the
current Tory party chairman former
Chancellor included a penalty
um I should say that Nadeem Sahari his
spokesperson has said that he doesn't
recognize the numbers that are being put
out there that he's never sought legal
advice for dealing with hmrc and insists
that his taxes are up to date and fully
paid in the UK
well you quoted what these spokesperson
there said foreign and I think that's
you know what we've seen is a series of
responses from a spokesperson from the
game zahar which which have been very
carefully uh worded responses uh which
haven't denied certain key elements um
of the story and frankly when you listen
to all of the statements put out which
which have also changed quite a lot uh
over time and I think the whole story
just doesn't add up and I think there
are really big questions there to be
answered about you know the apparent
failures to pay tax uh the apparent
penalty that he seems to be paid and the
fact that he can't give a straight
answer about what happened you know and
this is not just of anybody I mean if
anybody done this it would be serious
but this is someone who was Chancellor a
few months ago this is someone who's in
charge of the tax system of a country
just a few short months ago and who
originally soon as an appointed to be
chair of the conservative party and it
obviously speaks about Nadine zahari and
his behavior but it also speaks volumes
about Rishi act I've actually seen that
appointing him to the position of the
chair of the party and then leaving him
in that position
um now rather than taking decisive
action
do you agree with those in your party
who think he should be sacked over his
tax affairs
well I think his position seems
untenable you know I don't see how you
can how you can generate any trust or
any confidence given all of this I'm
hanging over him um but you know it's it
if you think about all of the stories
which are going around or if you see Mac
at the moment whether it's museums the
whole week or whether it's uh Richardson
not managing to fasten uh his own seat
belt it just gives us an impression of a
prime minister not being in control uh
you know not being able to run his party
not being able to run his country and
it's time for a change
okay and I do want to um ask you a
little bit about energy because I know
that's something that you wanted to talk
about today and labor suggesting keeping
the energy price guarantee at 2 500
pounds past April and the support is
supposed to diminish after that so how
long does labor want that support at
that level in place
so we know that in the second quarter of
this year the energy price cap is set to
rise up to 3 000 pounds and what we're
saying is that should stay at two and a
half thousand pounds um instead so that
would be funded by strengthening the
windfall tax and the windfall tax that
we first called for um over a year ago
and which still has holes in it which
we've been pressing the government again
and again to close and to tighten up the
legislation to make it truly effective
we would use some of that money from a
stronger windfall tax to keep that cap
at two and a half a thousand pounds in
the coming quarter now Beyond
becoming quarter we know the projections
suggests that the the energy prices may
come down and so let's see where we are
later in the year but for the immediate
uh period from April onward we believe
the cap should be kept at two and a half
thousand pounds the other really
important part of this though is that
you know we can't just have sticking
plasters at every turn to keep getting
us through uh the next few months that
is important that it's crucial to get
people through but we need to use this
time as well to invest for the long run
which is why we're saying alongside that
the media helps get people through the
months ahead we should also be investing
in clean power and insulating people's
homes because if you had energy coming
from clean sources if you had properties
in this country insulated property that
would bring down the average household
bill by 1400 pounds and that would make
a real difference in the long run
okay James Murray we appreciate your
time this morning thanks for joining us